- Back in the day,
before a lot of my videos
were going viral
probably one of my first
viral business statements were
"Get off the bitch train."
JT called in Jason Calacanis'
show This Week In Tech
and was trying to
make a decision.
I always talk about
pondering and debating
and I just finally got
fed up and I said,
"Dude, get off the bitch train."
And people liked it.
- [JT] Just moving forward.
- [Jason] Yeah, okay.
You got two great ideas,
Gary, your advice is?
- [Gary] Flip a coin, JT.
Are you equally
100% all-in on both?
Like Jason when he gets
pocket aces, bullets,
he's putting it all in.
- [Jason] Push!
- Are you equally feeling
that on both products?
- [JT] I am and I knew you
were going to ask me that.
I am passionate
about both concepts.
- So dude, honestly,--
- [JT] And that's why I'm
having such a hard time.
- You know what?
Honestly, you gotta
get off the bitch train
and just pick one.
You'll be fine.
You like them both,
it sounds that way.
- Ok, James.
- [Gary] Take care, man.
- Call in in a couple of weeks
and tell us that you started.
If you're still on the
bitch train, --
- [JT] Okay.
- [Jason] don't call back.
- [Gary] A couple weeks?
Tweet out tonight
that you got it goin'.
(light music)